johan a acheté un nouvel ensemble de
laveuse sécheuse le vendeur l'a
convaincue d'acheter aussi une garantie
prolongée à 270 dollars il avait un
argument béton
si johan ne fait pas de réclamation
après cinq ans la garantie lui sera
remboursé alors pourquoi s'en passer
cinq ans plus tard l'ensemble note
toujours pas flanché johan se rappelle
qu'il est temps de se faire rembourser
surprise le commerçant refuse net
non d'abord elle avait 90 jours après la
cinquième année pour faire sa demande
c'était écrit en doute sa facture mais
johanna la polluent et le vendeur s'est
bien gardé lui en parler quand il lui a
vendu sa garantie mais il ya pire
en lisant les petits caractères et
découvre que le remboursement n'est pas
dans l'argent
il s'agit en fait de le crédit qu'elle
obtiendra à condition d'acheter un
meuble ou un matelas le fin mot de
l'histoire
les vendeurs font rarement des cadeaux
méfiez vous de ce qui est trop beau